[Musique]
bonjour ravi de vous présenter cette
nouvelle émission sur Public Sénat
libre-échange un tête-à-tête de 30
minutes avec celles et ceux qui font
avancer l'économie française vous
connaissez évidemment leur entreprise
mais connaissez-vous l'homme ou la femme
qui la dirige aujourd'hui libre-échange
avec vous Véronique Bedag bonjour
bonjour David merci troll avec nous sur
Public Sénat de Nexity 1er promoteur
immobilier français petite question
est-ce que vous connaissez la série 10%
sur France 2 absolument bon mais là 10%
c'est pas c'est pas le cachet de l'agent
l'agent de star mais c'est le
pourcentage de femmes qui sont à la tête
d'une société côté en bourse en France
évidemment c'est peu évidemment la
parité semble hyper loin et en même
temps il y a une nouvelle vague de
dirigeante qui arrive à la tête
d'entreprise on l'a vu cette année chez
orange chez Veolia vous 2021 chez Nexity
mais quand même comment on apprécie la
chose on se dit trois sur 40 le compte
n'y est pas ou il se passe quelque chose
ah moi je pense qu'il se passe quelque
chose il y a 10 ans on n'aurait pas dit
ça donc quand même le temps le temps de
de du changement me paraît rapide et
intéressant parce que au fond il y a une
sorte d'accélération vous l'avez dit
vous-même ces nominations interviennent
ces deux ou trois dernières années donc
moi je pense que le temps change bon et
il y a cette phrase verse sortir je l'ai
exhumé Françoise Giroud ancienne
secrétaire d'État à la condition
féminine ça nous ramène 50 ans en
arrière qui disait la femme sera
vraiment légale de l'homme le jour où un
poste important on désignera une femme
incompétente comment l'apprécier un
demi-siècle après je pense que je dirais
pas les choses tout à fait de la même
façon mais je pense que malgré tout oui
non mais il y avait une idée derrière
cette phrase qui est assez forte qui est
qu'effectivement probablement l'exigence
sur les femmes dirigeantes et
dans un premier temps sans doute plus
forte que sur un homme dirigeant ça je
pense que c'est vrai ça reste c'est ça
ça améliorera au cours du temps mais
malgré tout je pense que en première
intention oui il y a une pression plus
forte sur la famille dirigeante c'est ce
qui explique que pour accéder au sommet
de l'entreprise ça reste toujours un
parcours un chemin se met en bus il y a
toujours encore une fois c'est difficile
d'accéder pour une femme tout en haut de
la pyramide de l'entreprise je pense que
oui parce que le au fond le système
n'était pas tout à fait favorable on a
quand même se dire les choses et puis
certaines femmes aussi se restreignent
au fond dans ses projections sur des
postes de direction et le fait que
advienne aujourd'hui des femmes
dirigeantes dans des sociétés cotées ça
construit au fond un modèle qui fait que
certains femmes se disent mais
finalement c'est possible donc je pense
que je suis très optimiste pour le futur
après la loi est passée par là aussi on
a eu cette loi copézie normale il y a 10
ans avec des quotas de femmes dans les
conseils administrations
enfin fin 2021 pour faire viceler un
petit peu et que les femmes soient plus
présentes dans les comités de direction
et donc voilà il faut de la loi aussi
pour faire avancer un peu de la loi pour
accélérer les processus oui ça j'ai
aucun doute là-dessus la parité chez
nixity à tous les étages on y est on
était la parité on est on a un Comex qui
est à peu près paritaire et on a à peu
près 46% de femmes dans ce qu'on appelle
le club sens c'est-à-dire les 100
premiers dirigeants de Nexity tant que
ça n'est pas si mal bon encore une autre
phrase celle de Christine Lagarde qui
dit j'ai 40 ans de vie professionnelle
président de la Banque centrale
européenne je n'ai encore jamais vu une
femme venir me demander une augmentation
de salaire bon ça change un peu je vous
rassure heureusement ça change
pas de moi non non je pense que je pense
que c'était sans doute un peu vrai je
pense que heureusement les temps
changent
mais il y a un rapport à l'argent encore
une fois oui sans doute avec plus de oui
sans doute peut-être plus de modération
plus de difficultés à évoquer ces sujets
là mais vraiment les choses changent
là-dessus comment êtes-vous devenus
numéro 1 évidemment vous allez me dire à
force de travail mais c'est pas
suffisant
le travail c'est quand même la première
marche j'ai envie de dire je pense que
c'était aussi au fond l'intérêt que
j'avais pour l'entreprise là le regard
que je pouvais porter sur l'entreprise
et puis évidemment le rapport que
j'entretenais avec Alain Dinant cet
échange de cette complicité au fond oui
sur la nature de l'entreprise sur le
fait que une entreprise ça n'est pas
neutre c'est d'avoir du tempérament ça
doit porter des projets ça doit au fond
avoir s'appuyer sur des piliers vous le
savez nous c'est la ville inclusive la
ville abordable la ville durable c'est
l'attention portée aux collaborateurs et
donc on fonce une sorte d'alignement sur
ces valeurs essentielles de l'entreprise
pour réussir c'est aussi une histoire de
rencontre celles qu'on provoque celle
qui sont fortuites c'est il y a un
facteur chance aussi d'ailleurs
[Musique]
vous avez raison c'est toute mon
histoire elle est faite de rencontre
c'est à dire que à un moment voilà vous
êtes plus ou moins jeune et puis vous
rencontrez quelqu'un qui est tout à coup
vous fait confiance et oui mais ce que
tu as pensé à ça et puis en fait oui non
non souvent et puis bah voilà on prend
un poste qui est quand même et puis
voilà l'histoire s'écrit comme ça donc
oui des rencontres moi je ma vie est
faite de rencontre de ce point de vue là
on loue votre détermination sans faille
c'est un trait de caractère dans lequel
vous reconnaissez
voir mieux c'est Bertrand Delanoë qui
vous qualifiant son temps bon vous étiez
dans la sphère publique il vous
qualifiait de guerrière et là je me suis
dit mais c'est un trade caractère
masculin ça l'histoire nous l'a montré
contemporaine et encore la plus récente
derrière oui ça c'est un adjectif que je
retrouve bien mais au fond le métier de
la promotion est un métier de guerrier
l'amitié de la promotion est un métier
difficile c'est un métier où il faut
trouver du terrain il faut travailler
avec les autorités locales il faut
travailler aussi avec l'environnement
c'est un métier de guerrier donc là je
pense que je suis parfaitement éliminé
avec l'ADN de mon entreprise qu'est-ce
qui a changé à la tête de l'entreprise
depuis que vous y êtes ça fait plus d'un
an encore une fois c'est assez récent
mais qu'est-ce qui a changé est-ce qu'il
y a une pattedags alors faudrait
demander ça mais collaborateurs
évidemment je pense que au fond mais
c'est mon histoire à moi le rapport au
collectivités c'est vraiment enrichi
puisque mais c'est de là où je j'ai
passé 12 ans à la ville de Paris je
comprends bien comment fonctionne une
collectivité donc vraiment le rapport à
la collectivité l'idée du partenariat
les offres qu'on peut faire pour au fond
aider des mères à construire
l'attractivité de leur ville ça c'est
vraiment très important et puisque je
porte aussi très profondément sur la
ville durable ça c'est accéléré c'était
déjà là mais ces choses-là s'accélèrent
l'essentiel autre carrière Véronique
bedague était consacré au service public
vous l'avez dit donc ex secrétaire
général pardon je suis un peu le CV de
la ville de Paris sous Bertrand Delanoë
ancienne directrice de cabinet de Manuel
Valls pendant trois ans à Matignon
qu'est-ce qui vous a poussé à ne plus
être au service de l'État c'est le
sentiment d'avoir fait le tour je pose
la question benoîtement au fond de
c'étaient une envie que j'avais enfin
moi je vous avais j'ai aussi passé trois
ans aux États-Unis qui m'ont beaucoup
marqué et les Américains ont été au fond
monétaire et les Américains ont l'idée
que on a le droit si on veut même c'est
plutôt bien de changer de vie à certains
moments et j'avais gardé ça au fond au
fond de moi en me disant mais au fond un
jour si je peux je ferai ça je rejouerai
et quand je suis sortie de Matignon
forcément après trois années très
épouvantes je me suis dit ben voilà
c'est le moment rejoue essaie essaie
quelque chose de très différent et donc
j'ai cherché un poste en entreprise
quelle différence justement d'ailleurs
en termes de management entre le
l'administration et la sphère privée et
bien j'ai envie de dire en réalité pas
tant que ça parce que le management je
pense qu'on a sans doute plus de liberté
de marge de manœuvre dans une entreprise
privée mais le management est évidemment
extrêmement important dans la sphère
publique donc moi je ne pense pas qu'il
y ait il faut
on arrive là où on doit arriver si on
dessine un chemin si on emmène les
équipes avec soi sur ce chemin là ça
c'est vrai dans le public comme dans le
privé il y a pas de différence il faut
avoir une vision il faut emmener les
équipes avec soi quand vous sortez donc
de cet quelque chose de Matignon c'est
une sauce Matignon confirmer vous allez
frapper à la porte de Nexity Nexity
passe seulement le groupe on comprend
bien n'a pas été choisi par hasard alors
en fait quand je suis sortie de Matignon
je me souviens j'ai fait quelque chose
qui fait sourire beaucoup mais j'avais
pris la liste des 120 premiers
entreprises côté française je vais
regarder toutes les entreprises qui
avaient un lien avec la construction de
la ville qui au fond de ma passion moi
j'ai passé 12 ans à la ville de Paris la
construction de la ville le logement
comment on vit ensemble l'espace public
je trouve ça extraordinaire ça ça parle
à tout le monde au fond et donc j'avais
sélectionné un certain nombre de
d'entreprises qui travaillaient sur ces
sujets là et puis le hasard la rencontre
quelqu'un me dit il y a quelqu'un avec
que tu dois absolument rencontrer si tu
veux faire ça c'est à l'Indien
personnage très fort ah oui c'est un
personnage très fort oui bien sûr parce
que au fond il est il est il a des
convictions extrêmement profondes
il a eu je pense
avant beaucoup d'autres l'idée que une
entreprise ça n'est pas neutre ça ne
fait pas que du profit ça intervient ça
doit être utile au monde et ça a de la
responsabilité donc il y avait vraiment
ça qui qui moi me permettait au fond de
passer je pense plus souplement du
public au privé parce que même en
entreprise au fond il y avait des choses
que j'étais capable de porter donc je
peux croisement finalement de l'accent
de l'état des entreprises
ce mot ce pas logique oui oui c'est
assez logique avec effectivement
malgré tout dans l'entreprise beaucoup
plus de souplesse l'entreprise est plus
souple et sans doute beaucoup plus agile
assez nativement que malgré tout une
administration publique chiffre
d'affaires 5 milliards d'euros vivre une
collaborateurs donc c'est quand même
voilà il faut être agile l'entreprise se
doit d'être agit d'autant plus que on
voit se succéder Véronique bec de plus
en plus de crises on a eu les crises
évidemment sanitaires avec le covid
climatique cet été encore une fois avec
la canicule la sécheresse géopolitique
avec la guerre en Ukraine et là je me
dis pour les dirigeants que vous êtes
autant d'incertitudes en même temps
cumulé c'est difficile à mon avis non de
piloter sereinement j'insiste sur le
sereinement une entreprise parce qu'on
doit gérer des crises en permanence mais
là ça vous ramène quelque part aussi à
Matignon on est dans la gestion de crise
permanente aussi oui alors moi je pense
que les entreprises sont résilientes et
ce qui a au cœur de l'entreprise c'est
que l'idée que la crise offre des
opportunités donc c'est ça qu'on regarde
il y a une crise
Nexity a montré au cours du temps que
c'était une entreprise à la fois grande
mais extrêmement agile capable de se
déplacer ce qu'on est en train de faire
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui très clairement
moins de français peuvent acheter nos
logements mais beaucoup de français
cherchent des locations nous ce qu'on
est en train de faire c'est au fond de
déployer des solutions au niveau billet
géré pour permettre aux Français qui ont
besoin de se loger en louant de trouver
au fond une offre donc on est vraiment
extrêmement agile face aux situations
encore une fois avec le temps
d'incertitude maximale comment on garde
le cap avec autant de là je pense que en
période de crise oui mais en période de
crise et de troubles puisque jamais il
faut garder un cap parce que sinon vous
êtes emporté par des incertitudes par
des donc moi je pense que justement dans
la crise il faut savoir où on va mais
c'est pas facile de piloter un groupe
encore une fois non mais je suis pas
toute seule on est 8200 j'ai vraiment
des collaborateurs merveilleux engagés
donc je me sens jamais seul au fond on
est vraiment un groupe on y va donc j'ai
pas ce sentiment de ce marché retombera
dessus
honnêtement l'entreprise c'est où elle
va on l'a dit on a une manifesterdée au
mois de septembre on sait qu'elle est
notre chemin on sait ce qu'on veut faire
je pense que toutes les équipes autour
de moi donnent le meilleur de ce
qu'elles peuvent donner voilà
allons-y bon parmi les incertitudes de
ronic Bedag autre sujet il y a
l'inflation c'est un vrai sujet on pense
qu'elle a disparu des écrans radars non
elle est revenue et en force on est à 6%
en France on a de la chance parce que en
Europe c'est 10% c'est lié d'ailleurs la
petite du gouvernement mais c'est pas le
sujet du jour en revanche c'est 6% ça
l'a mis complètement le pouvoir d'achat
notamment des salariés résultats on
assiste de plus en plus à des
revendications salariales ma question
c'est simple c'est jusqu'au l'entreprise
les entreprises au-delà même du casexity
doivent aller pour compenser cette
inflation et protéger leur
collaborateurs je pense en tout cas que
les entreprises ne peuvent pas rester
immobile face à ces sujets là évidemment
cette inflation a un effet très
important sur le pouvoir d'achat en
particulier des rémunérations les moins
élevés de l'entreprise donc nous on a
ouvert des négociations les a anticipées
et puis évidemment on va avoir un
traitement différencié en fonction du
niveau de revenus de nos collaborateurs
et on fera ce qu'on pourra faire le
mieux possible pour les aider à passer
cette période qui n'est vraiment pas
très simple on l'avait déjà fait l'année
dernière pour protéger pour partie par
entièrement c'est pas le rôle de
l'entreprise pour partie oui forcément
après cette idée dans le débat public
soute notamment par par la CGT mais pas
seulement de réindexer les salaires sur
l'inflation comme les d'ailleurs le SMIC
le SMIC est indexé sur l'inflation
est-ce qu'il faut c'est une réflexion
au-delà du cas de Nexity encore une fois
et ce qu'il faut réfléchir à ça ou
est-ce que l'histoire nous a montré que
après les choses peuvent s'emballer et
je pense que on sait tous que
l'inflation est un mal extrêmement
dangereux pour l'économie c'est-à-dire
que en période d'inflation galopante les
calculs économiques ont du mal à
s'effectuer donc je pense qu'il y a
consensus aujourd'hui sur le fait qu'il
faut que l'inflation au fond ralentisse
c'est bien ce que sont en train de faire
tenter de faire les banques centrales
avec
l'immobilier
partout et on sait très bien que
l'indexation des salaires sur
l'inflation et quelque chose qui
entretient cette pierre cette spirale
inflationniste donc
indiscutablement Nexity en tout cas
protège le pouvoir d'achat de ses
salariés
on va travailler sur ces sujets là dans
les dans les semaines qui viennent et je
vous l'ai dit on l'a on l'a avancé on va
utiliser tous les instruments qui sont à
notre disposition pour effectivement
accompagner nos salariés dans cette
période qui est vraiment très complexe
ne serait-ce que on parle d'inflation
mais ne serait-ce que les factures
énergétiques aujourd'hui c'est un sujet
pour tous les Français nous on le voit
oui on a un bouclier mais nous on vous
avez raison mais nous vous savez qu'on
est aussi syndic de copropriété et donc
ces sujets là sont vraiment au cœur de
ce que l'on fait aujourd'hui et
n'oubliez pas que le fait d'être en
bouclier tarifaire ne suppose pas
forcément que vous payez la même facture
que l'année dernière ça signifie qu'il y
a un plafond mais le plafond peut
signifier que vous payez une facture
deux fois plus élevée que l'année
dernière c'est ce qu'on voit dans nos
copropriétés donc ça n'est pas le
bouclier tarifaire est un instrument
extrêmement puissant qui ralentit au
fond cette hausse mais ça n'est pas ça
ne dit pas que vous ne payez pas plus
que l'année dernière et puis il y a
renouvellement de contrats qui sont en
cours nous on est en train de déployer
chez Nexity un certain nombre d'outils
pour aider les copropriété que nous
sommes que nous conseillons sur tous ces
sujets qui sont vraiment très prégnants
dans les copropriétés aujourd'hui bon
pour aider les salariés il y a
l'actionnariat salarié je sais que vous
y croyez fort mais les syndicats
certains syndicats vous diront que c'est
pas avec ça qu'on décroche un crédit
immobilier pour s'acheter un logement
neuf chez Nexity ou pas d'ailleurs non
mais chez nous pour le coup
l'actionnariat salarié c'est une
histoire ancienne et quand les bonnes
années très clairement les syndicats me
demandent ce qu'on a fait l'année
dernière au mois de juillet les
attributions gratuites d'actions chez
nous c'est très important
90% des salariés de Nexity sont
actionnaires et tout le monde y tient et
c'est un c'est une position dans
l'entreprise qui est extrêmement
importante autre sujet Véronique bédag
les démissions qui sont au plus haut
depuis 2008 3% des ruptures
conventionnelles qui sont à des niveaux
records des tensions sur les
recrutements que sûrement peut-être
aussi dans votre domaine et ce qui est
un malaise quand même chez les certains
salariés qui veulent on sent bien on
revient on Rebout avec le sud avant être
mieux payé mais aussi donner du sens à
leur boulot
c'est exactement ça alors moi je dois
dire que forcément on a des démissions
mais on ne sent pas d'un mouvement très
puissant de démission mais parce que
l'entreprise fait sens je pense que les
combats qu'on mène sur la ville
inclusive sur le bac carbone vous savez
que nous on a une trajectoire bâtard
bonne qui est plus exigeante que la
réglementation c'est combats qui sont
des combats du quotidien qui sont qui
ont une vraie matérialité dans chacun
des dossiers que l'on porte ça donne du
sens au fond au travail que font toutes
nos équipes aujourd'hui quand nos
équipes de copropriété aident les
copropriétaires à traiter leur facture
d'énergie je vous assure que ça fait
sens ça fait vraiment sens pour tout le
monde si on fait bien notre boulot on va
quand même faciliter le passage de nos
clients qui est quand même est un peu
complexe dans le moment
soit conserver ses talents en attirer
l'extérieur mais conserver aussi ce
qu'on a absolument et puis je pense que
et puis je pense qu'il y a une vraie
demande qui est très intéressante
déjà ne pas que de participer à la
transformation et l'idée que le monde
doit se transformer et donc cette
demande de d'être acteur de la
transformation et nous à la fois parce
qu'on est une structure extrêmement
décentralisée qui a beaucoup
d'initiatives sur le terrain et que la
rapidité de la transformation de nos
métiers le passage à la ville bacarbonne
et vraiment très accélérée fait que
chacun dans l'entreprise peut au fond
contribuer avec ce qu'il est avec ce
qu'il sait faire avec ce qu'il a envie
de faire à toutes ces transformations et
ça je pense que pour nous c'est
extrêmement précieux dans le moment
d'abord parce que on bouge plus vite que
les autres et ensuite parce que chacun
des salariés Nexity se dit il peut
changer une partie de ce qu'on fait là
où il aime de plus en plus d'entreprises
affirment leur responsabilité sociétale
c'est dans le discours elle se doit de
raison d'être d'ailleurs
ils nous disent la main sur le cœur que
oui elles en font un maximum pour leurs
salariés pour la planète comment
s'assurer pour ceux qui nous regardent
que tout ça c'est pas de la com
je pense que dans nos projets à nous
c'est assez simple les projets ils se
voient nous par exemple on était il y a
15 jours on a été on a reçu le prix du
premier promoteur bacarbone de France
c'est nous qui produisons le plus au
fond de logements bas carbone dans le
pays donc ça c'est un c'est une preuve
au fond donc nous on est vraiment sur
des sujets très pratiqués pratiques qui
se mesure au fond assez bien donc cet
engagement pour les entreprises au-delà
de la nécessité il faut il faut qu'elle
se note de moyens il faut que il faut
qu'il y ait de l'épreuve il y a l'amour
oui mais par exemple on a dit ville
inclusive on y tient vraiment et ce
qu'on a fait c'est des pensions de
famille sans marge c'est à dire qu'on
construit des unités de 10 20 logements
que l'on vend à des bailleurs sociaux ou
à des associations sans marge pour
faciliter la sortie au fond de de
personnes sans domicile fixe de la rue
c'est moi je pense que c'est une vraie
preuve d'amour ça on va en faire en 26
on en aura fait à peu près 2000 donc et
moi je pense que ces engagements que
vous prenez vos salariés sont les
premiers à voir si ça fait sens ou pas
et donc nous parce que parce qu'on le
fait vraiment parce que je les inaugure
ces pensions de famille on montre que on
parle de la ville inclusive non on y
croit vraiment et on le fait et on donne
une partie de notre substance sur ces
engagements là donc je pense que nous
salariés sont les premiers au fond à
être les gardiens de ces engagements et
sinon sur les résultats est-ce que les
résultats financiers comptent autant que
les résultats extra-financiers chez
Nexity est-ce que c'est aussi
l'important avec l'autre désormais à la
trajectoire carbone le bien-être des
salariés pour nous ça l'est je ne dirais
pas que pour les marchés ce soir
vraiment encore donc un sujet et un
sujet bon il y a un contexte on parle du
logement immobilier Véronique Béda qui
s'annonce de plus en plus compliqué
encore une fois parce que on l'évoquait
cette remontée des taux d'intérêt qui
est en cours on a ce ralentissement
économique et c'est lié à l'inflation
les pénuries matériaux aussi voilà
est-ce que on risque ou pas l'idée n'est
pas de se faire peur mais ce qu'on
risque une tempête sur le marché
immobilier est-ce que tout est réuni
ça veut dire qu'elle se matériaule en
tout cas ce que l'on peut dire
aujourd'hui
sans parler de tempête parce que est-ce
qu'on peut dire aujourd'hui en tout cas
c'est qu'il y a deux grands éléments
qu'on est en train de voir qui sont
effectivement vous avez raison une forte
diminution du pouvoir d'achat immobilier
des Français à la fois parce que
l'inflation est là mais aussi parce que
les taux d'intérêt montent et puis aussi
parce que les règles prudentielles de
d'accession à l'emprunt ont été
profondément transformés et puis donc il
y a moins d'accédents à la propriété
aujourd'hui le marché
du logement collectif neuf je crois
était de -20% au premier semestre là
j'ai vu un article ce matin dans le
Journal disant que les prêts étaient
réduits de 30%
les trois derniers mois donc évidemment
il y a moins de pouvoir d'achat
immobilier mais ça n'empêche pas mais ça
n'empêche pas le besoin de logement le
besoin de logement il est là et comme le
besoin de logement il est là pour des
raisons
démographie pour des raisons aussi de
besoins de rénovation et bien ce qui est
en train de se coincer là c'est le le
secteur du de la location aujourd'hui
nous on a beaucoup moins d'offres en
location et quand on a une offre en
location on a beaucoup plus de demandes
donc c'est ça qui est en train de se
passer en réalité et à ceux qui
reprochent c'est quelque chose qu'on
entend parfois enfin souvent en tout cas
que l'immobilier ne fait beaucoup trop
cher et n'est plus abordable et certains
qui pensent parfois que c'est la faute
notamment des promoteurs mobiliers qui
ont des marges trop élevées on leur
répond quoi ces gens-là on répond
d'abord que aujourd'hui je pense que
malgré tout l'avantage de de
l'immobilier neuf qui quand même
attirent toujours de nombreux acheteurs
c'est que malgré tout il est aux normes
il va vieillir 10-15 ans sans travaux il
va permettre quand même de maîtriser la
facture énergétique donc je pense que
tout ça se pèse mais il y a cette idée
que comme les prix n'ont fait monter
depuis maintenant plus de 10 ans il y a
un moment où les acheteurs n'ont plus
les moyens et ne peuvent plus suivre
c'est ça le sujet
puisque je vous ai dit que il y a 20% de
moins de ventes de logement neufs au
premier semestre donc oui donc et les
empreintes diminuent à peu près 30%. ce
qui veut dire que français qui rêvent
comme nous tous évidemment de se loger
sans trop se ruiner on se dit en même
temps que voilà potentiellement ça
pourrait baisser en même temps qu'il y a
des besoins des demandes qui est là qui
est présente et une inflation qui est là
avec le coût des matériaux voilà comment
comment on se projette sur les
prochaines années quand on est
primo-accédant quand on est acheteur de
logement et bien écoutez d'abord je
pense que nous on est jeune on se dit
qu'on est quasiment exclu pardon ça
dépend où vous trouvez mais oui moi ce
qui me touche beaucoup dans ce qui nous
arrive aujourd'hui c'est pour être très
clair des jeunes qui ne peuvent pas se
faire aider par leurs parents ont
vraiment du mal à devenir primo-accédant
moi les premiers primo-accédants jeunes
que j'ai vu revenir Nexity c'était dans
un programme de BRS qu'on avait fait à
Villeurbanne où vous savez c'est un
système où la ville ou en tout cas les
autorités locales achètent le foncier et
les acheteurs n'achètent que les murs
donc c'est beaucoup moins cher c'est ça
dépend de la part du prix du foncier
mais c'est
30-50% moins cher que et là on voit
revenir déjà et moi je pense que ça
c'est très important parce que c'est
c'est aussi la cohésion sociale de notre
pays comment on fait vernis pour
faire baisser ces questions qu'on veut
vous poser un milliard de fois pour
faire baisser les prix des logements en
France vous allez me dire il faut
construire plus et vous avez raison mais
c'est déjà quand même un sujet le fait
que
le moins enfin c'était un Big Bang mais
dans le mauvais sens
donc malgré tout c'est on peut faire
plein de choses et nous on le fait on
revoit nos modes constructifs on fait
des achats en gros on essayait de
rationaliser
mais malgré tout vous êtes dans un le
monde où les au fond les logements
construits sont peu nombreux et la
demande est très forte et vous avez des
prix de fonciers très élevés donc tant
qu'on fait donc c'est le prix du foncier
donc ça nous renvoie au sujet des maires
peut-être qu'ils les maires qui ne
délivrent pas assez de construire leur
place aussi oui mais les maires ont
comment dirais moi je pense depuis le
début que sur ce sujet là il n'y a pas
de consensus sur le besoin de logement
dans ce pays il y a déjà pas de
consensus c'est-à-dire qu'il y a pas de
il y a pas d'explication au fond et et
d'accord sur est-ce qu'on construit
assez de logements ou pas notre
conviction à nous c'est que on construit
alors 375 000 logements par an à mon
avis ça aide beaucoup moins dans les
années qui viennent il en faut 500000
si vous prenez aussi la rénovation parce
que nous on prend la rénovation
maintenant on fait vraiment du neuf et
du rénover de façon très naturelle donc
c'est 500 à 600 000 logements donc tant
que tant qu'on ne donnera pas au fond
une impulsion et il n'y aura pas une
réflexion collective autour de au fond
si on a vraiment besoin moins de 500 à
600 000 logements soit neuf soit
rénovées au fond ou et comment on le
fait les mères ils sont vraiment au fond
assez seul ils n'ont plus de ressources
propres on a supprimé la taxe
d'habitation la CVAE bon et puis il y a
aucune raison que les décisions prises
par chacun des mers la somme de toutes
ces décisions là prise de façon très
décentralisée et c'est normal arrive
magiquement au 500 000 ou 600 000
logements dont on a besoin mais l'État
n'est absent la taille est absent même
de la discussion puisque l'état de
derrière il y a pas de mots tout ça on a
du mal à être optimiste
parce que le besoin le vraiment c'est un
marché qui est au fond très fluide et le
besoin de logement étant voilà il est là
ça coûte plus cher aussi oui et non
c'est pas toujours ça ça n'est pas
toujours vrai et nous on a vraiment
beaucoup travaillé depuis longtemps les
modes il faut vraiment travailler les
modes constructifs vous avez raison
c'est cher si on construit comme avant
et puis on veut faire du vert ensuite
mais si on prend le sujet dès le début
on est capable de nous dans de nombreux
cas de de construire à peu près au même
prix aujourd'hui petite question
là-dessus toujours pas de pénurie de
matériaux je suis Nexity les tuiles tout
ça pardonné j'ai le droit de croiser les
doigts là non bon voilà donc on y est et
donc ça veut dire des retards de
livraison aussi dans les dans les
programmes à cause de ces difficultés
d'approvisionnement potentiellement
écoutez nous on a eu des retards non pas
non pas vraiment à cause parce que nous
je dois le dire que on en a pas vraiment
enfin j'ai pas de connaissance de
chantier que ce serait arrêté à cause de
pénurie de matériaux alors peut-être de
façon mais non surtout nous on a un peu
ralenti simplement parce que la crise
étant là on a au mois de juin et au mois
de juillet réévaluer chacun de nos
programmes pour voir leur propositions
oui on a pu différer parce qu'on a
négocié on a négocié le foncier on a
négocié les les contrats on a Ret
nettoyer les projets donc oui les
retards c'était plutôt ça c'était un
moment de réévaluation au fond le monde
change l'inflation est différente est-ce
que nos programmes tiennent merci de
passer nous voir pour cette première
émission libre-échange fut un plaisir
merci David voilà libre échange c'est
fini pour aujourd'hui mission à voir
revoir sur Xéna il y a le replay bien
sûr sur public c'est la point fr
rendez-vous le mois prochain
[Musique]